ich würde sagen jetzt ziehen das ganze
jetzt mal an und dann zeige ich euch mal
wie es aussieht so sieht es aus wenn man
mal runter geht ja was geht ab und jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
mir auch danke ja heute war wirklich ein
sehr sehr aufregenden tag ich war
nämlich zum ersten mal in meinem leben
in einer kik filiale sollte ich glaube
ich eigentlich jeder von euch kennen an
die die es nicht kennen
kik ist ein kaufhaus wo man klamotten
kaufen kann in erster linie zumindest
eine heute auch aufgefallen ist dass
dort viele sachen gibt die gar nichts
mit kleidung zu tun haben also wenn ihr
nach diesem video noch bock habt dass
ich das ganze auch noch mit diesen
günstigeren sachen mache wie keine
ahnung was ist halt so kleinigkeiten
spielsachen und so weiter wenn ihr bock
drauf habt lasst jetzt mal nen fetten
daumen nach oben daran sich dass ich
glaube sehr viele menschen denken immer
kik hat schlechte qualität oder das wird
glaube ich so damit verbunden leute ganz
kurze pause und zwar gibt es auf dem
kopf wie youtube kanal wieder ein neues
video von mir diesmal geht es um die
lustigsten lehrer sprüche der lehrer
sagt sophie sofie bitte raus dann fragt
zu viel her warum dann sagt der lehrer
weil aber niemand interessiert dann hat
sie geantwortet
dann können sie gleich mitkommen erster
link in der beschreibung da kommt ihr
zum video einfach draufklicken ich
wünsche euch viel spaß und ja jetzt
geht's hier weiter und ich bin letztens
mal wieder an so einem klick hier
vorbeigefahren und habe mir gedacht
warum jackson das nicht mehr abkaufen
doch mal klamotten und das habe ich halt
heute morgen gemacht ich bin hingefahren
habe gedacht da kommt nimmt man ein
bisschen geld in die hand also es war
wirklich günstig würde sagen schaut mal
kurz rein ich war im laden so dass
aussetzer und so leute das lustige ist
genau bei uns um die ecke eigentlich
gibt es einen kick nicht noch nie
gesehen habe ich wohne jetzt schon seit
über einem jahr ich bin jetzt hier
gerade mal hingefahren wir gehen jetzt
da rein das lustige ist eigentlich gut
ob ich mir das jetzt glaubt noch nicht
aber ich war noch nie in meinem ganzen
leben in irgendeinem kick ja ich hab das
als ich hab zwar schon mal so
reingeguckt aber so wirklich drin war
ich noch nie und deswegen würde ich
sagen beginnen
mal rein jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
[Musik]
das ist auf jeden fall sehr sehr groß da
gibt es die mitarbeiter streben es an
alter also sowas für fünf euro ist ja
schon recht gut
leute ich habe einiges gefunden ich
glaube ich habe jetzt insgesamt 40 euro
ausgeben für schuhe hose einen politik
ein polymer sohn haben keine ahnung wie
das genau heißt wer dir gleich sehen und
ein t shirt 40 euro ein ganzes outfit
und ich muss sagen ich hatte so das
vorurteil dass die sachen darin wirklich
nicht gut sind aber das hat sich gar
nicht mal so schlecht angefühlt
natürlich ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt
zu 100 prozent mein style
aber ich habe das beste versucht also
wir fahren jetzt zurück oder sage ich
euch das ganze mal so jetzt willkommen
zurück man muss auch sagen ich war heute
morgen bestimmt man 35 stunden im laden
habe alles durchsucht hat natürlich
nicht jetzt durch den gefilmt sondern
nur so ein paar sequenzen und habt finde
ich auf jeden fall das beste
herausgeholt was besseres gab es in dem
ding nicht das war echt groß aber die
meisten hosen die ich dort ja mir
angeschaut habe die ging gar nicht also
ich habe wirklich nur eine hose gefunden
mit der ich so ein bisschen zufrieden
war ich bin mal gespannt wie sie sitzt
ich hatte sie jetzt noch nicht an wir
haben ein weißes t-shirt wir haben
schuhe
ich war zehn euro kostet echt kann und
noch so ein überziehen wenn ich das mal
ja ich bin mal gespannt wie es ausgeht
ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal die sache
und ihr könnt ja aber in die kommentare
schreiben
das gefällt also ich muss sagen wir
fangen mal an mit dem t shirt und zwar
ist es ein weißes t shirt mit schwarz
streifen am rand die aber gar nicht
komplett drum rum gehen sondern nur halt
das ding hat 5 eur 990 euro kostet hier
sind auch noch schwarze streifen und das
ist von der marke alice m86 und ich habe
mir gedacht also entweder bis jetzt dumm
oder das ist die marke schreibst du
gerne in die kommentare wenn ich falsch
liege aber von robert geiss ja an die
denn jetzt nicht kennen das ist ein
deutscher millionär wird auch eine show
im fernsehen und ich meine dass wir
seine marke oder es war mal
merkel keine ahnung so zu dem t shirt
habe ich folgende hose gekauft und zwar
so eine schwarze hose ich finde es
eigentlich immer wichtig dass ihr unten
ein bisschen enger wird ja es gab keine
einzige hose bei der das der fall ist
das war die ängste hose ich bin mal
gespannt wie die aussieht sehr schwarz
schlicht hat sogar muss man auch sagen
20 euro kostet ist natürlich nicht viel
nur ich hab auch bei zara schon mal eine
hose für 20 euro gut
erst passt auf ich mach mal weiter mit
den schuhen und zwar habe ich die schuhe
in seinem olivgrün heißt das glaube ich
noch etwas dunkelgrün sehen aus wie
keine ahnung wir können jetzt eigentlich
auch adidas logo drauf sein finde ich
gar nicht mal so schlecht sind also auf
jeden fall ein sneaker angelehnt die man
so bei snacks oder foot locker kaufen
können erinnert mich vielleicht sogar
meisten new balance i falls ihr das
kennt keine ahnung ob ich das gerade
richtig ausgesprochen habe auf jeden
fall haben die wirklich nur 12 euro
gekostet zwölf jahren 99 glaube ich
finde ich absolut okay ja ist ein
vernünftiger schuh ich bin nur gespannt
wieder sind also beschwerden kann man
sich da auf jeden fall eher weniger und
zum schluss habe ich noch ein teil aus
und zwar so zum über schmeißen einfach
so ein kariertes hemd bin ich auch gar
nicht mal so schlecht
das wäre glaube ich so das einzige teil
wo ich sagen würde haye das kann ich mir
wirklich vorstellen öfter mal anzuziehen
soll sich jetzt nicht blöd anhören ich
finde die anderen sachen auf keinen fall
von der qualität her schlecht oder so es
ist nur nicht so mein look ich würde
sagen wir ziehen das ganze jetzt mal an
und dann zeige ich euch mal wie es
aussieht und wir können das ganze in den
kommentaren mit punkten von eins bis
zehn 1 das schlechteste das beste
bewerten also los geht's heute also
gerade habe ich nur das t shirt an und
die hose ja ich finde so wie es jetzt
aussieht ist es okay das problem ist nur
die hose ist wirklich extrem weit das
ist eigentlich genau meine größe und ich
habe jetzt hier unten zweimal
umgekrempelt ich bin eigentlich gar
nicht dafür ein von sowas würde ist halt
unten weg extrem weit also keine ahnung
wer so einen geschmack natürlich jedem
das seine aber meins ist es nicht ich
finde das sieht halt wirklich sehr aus
als für die hose so extrem hängen obwohl
die gar nicht unbedingt mal zu groß ist
versteht ihr was ich meine also hier ist
es wirklich sehr weit oben sitzt sie eng
und unten ist sie auch sehr weit liegt
halt echt nicht so cool aus aber besser
kann ich das nicht weil wir haben
das hemd und die schule und das ist
probierte leute ich habe jetzt noch das
oberteil hier drüber gezogen und die
schuhe an ich muss sagen irgendwie
stimmt da was mit den größen liegt das
hier soll m sein also ich habe
eigentlich echt wirklich überall
außerdem t shirts und das ist mir
wirklich
also sitzt nicht so gut so sieht es aus
wenn man mal runter geht ja die schon
das t shirt finde ich also eigentlich
wirklich am besten weil er schon muss
ich nämlich sagen die sitzen bequem die
sind sehr leicht und es fällt gar nicht
auf dass sie günstig sind wie finde ich
hose und dieses karierte ding hier
sitzen leider extrem weit ich weiß nicht
woran es liegt habe ich normalerweise
sonst nicht aber gut also als kleines
fazit das gut ist ich habe jetzt mal da
eingekauft ich weiß dass es sachen die
sind qualitativ okay vieles spricht
allerdings nicht wirklich meinem
geschmack da waren auch eher ältere
leute heute eine ahnung ob die sich eher
auf ältere leute beziehen wollen
und die jüngere zielgruppe so ein
bisschen ausschließen möchten aber so
sachen für wirklich jugendliche habe ich
dort nicht unbedingt gefunden vielleicht
lag's an der vier jahre keine ahnung ist
nur meine persönliche meinung und so
sieht's aus ich würde mir selber dafür
maximal vier punkte geben das war's mit
dem kick video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen lassen doch nach oben wenn ich
die anderen produkte von dort auch mal
testen soll würde ich sehr gern machen
und wir sehen uns über folgen wieder
haut rein